there are some chasms so deep and so
wide we find it hard to imagine how
we'll ever make it to the other side
that space between who we are and who we
want to be the gaps between our high
ideals in our base realities the
distance between what we say and what we
really mean the raging river that flows
between what actually happens in our
convenient memories the lies we tell
ourselves our lakes overflowing their
banks flooding our speech with waters
caustic and rank the only bridge is the
truth passing through me and you as we
look one another I too i but so often
that look is filled with our hesitations
and we can't help but glance to the side
see we've long ago let go of the
language with which we describe our
softer parts we learn early that those
with sauce the heart suffer so we allow
lean emotions to rain never noticing
that only strain has been the fruit of
our restraints we have an escape pane
and our battle scars are far from faint
yet and still despite our desire and
willingness to heal we often find
ourselves fighting hard in the paint
holding on to false images of everything
we ain't so while our dreams coincide i
feels collide and we want to know one
another but think we can't the gulf
between empathy and equity is as
unfathomable as the fissures that line
our collective integrity and we spend
eternal interno t's trying to translate
that into virtue perhaps you have met
one or two of the virtuous on your path
there are only very few and I know that
I have from time to time mistaken
pretenders for real yet still make room
for the possibility that is I who's been
pretending please bear with me I'm still
Mensing but I'm no longer bending to the
will of my injuries nor my injurers I
much prefer to stretch my arms like
newts
until I become the sky I'd rather
stretch my tongue with truth i bridge to
cross when we look one another in the
eye but the tongue like the heart gets
tired
the weak make it hard for the strong to
stay inspired like the lost prevent the
found from escaping the mire and the
degraded stop the enlightened from
taking us higher but no matter what you
hear from the mouths of these liars we
are one people with one destiny in the
common enemy that's why it really
stresses me to see our heart so tattered
our minds so scattered our egos so
easily flattered we're enslaved yet
think about shackles as gifts rather
than resist our masters we let them
widen our wrists like mindless material
junkies we seek that which lowers not
lifts but somewhere in our midst there's
been a paradigm shifts justice is
getting restless in exchange are you
find it useless to separate their souls
from their brains their truth is
ingrained their integrity in sustained
let me call your attention to those who
serve as examples those who daily give
their all but their reserves are still
ample those who battle friend and foe
yet their hope is never trampled they
make music never sample and the world's
ugly could never cancel the fullness and
the sweetness of their composition nor
the unadulterated truth of their mission
it's time we shut our mouths and listen
close our eyes and pray but the humility
and the guidance to follow them so the
way thank you
[Music]
thank y'all so much you have no idea how
fulfilling and energizing that is for
the past three years I've had the
privilege of Co designing with my
neighbors a space in New Orleans known
as under the bridge in 1966 interstate
ten landed on the Treme neighborhood
displacing 326 black owned businesses
over 300 live oak trees effectively
destroying the region's most successful
black commercial district disrupting
intergenerational wealth and truly
unraveling the fabric of the nation's
oldest african-american neighborhood
today after 45 years of community
advocacy after 500 hours of community
engagement and 80 hours of community
design we are so excited that in 2018
after capturing the voices of thousands
of residents in the support of our local
federal and philanthropic partners as
the city celebrates 300 years of
transforming the worlds we will get to
transform 19 blocks under the interstate
it's a community space and some black
owned businesses in the form of the
Claiborne corridor cultural innovation
districts
we will be bridging time we will bridge
memory we will bridge disparity and
injustice and we can't wait to see you
all on the other sides thank you
[Applause]
[Music]